(upbeat music)
- Today we're talking
about mom friendships,
friendships after you become a mom.
- Mom BFFs.
- [Kristin] Fun stuff.
- And we've invited a non-mom
BFF, Ms. Kristin Chirico
who's just a regular BFF.
What's up dude?
- What up?
No babies for me.
(laughter)
No babies, just sandwiches.
If you're not a parent, you are frustrated
when your friend that has a
child can't go out with you.
When you are a parent,
you are frustrated when
your friend that does not have a child,
doesn't understand your limitation.
- Somebody who's a
non-parent and it's like,
well just go out, you see
your kid all the time.
I know I see my kid all the time,
but I love them more than anything
- Your heart hurts
- in the world.
- When I don't see her.
- Oh my God, look I'm gonna
like cry just thinking about it
because I love them so
much that the idea of
not putting them to bed
for one night makes me sad.
- Until I enrolled Delilah
in some sort of program
and actually met other moms with kids
who were the same age,
I felt like I was completely
alone in the world.
- That's really sad.
- It's isolating.
- It is isolating.
- It's really isolating
and I will tell you
like on maternity leave,
you're at home with your baby by yourself
trying to figure it out and
if you don't have somebody
there to talk to or commiserate with,
you can feel really, really lonely.
One of my biggest regrets
is not joining a mom's group
when I was pregnant.
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
- Honestly,
however I didn't even
know that was a thing.
- So what happens to your
friends when you give birth?
They just leave.
- Sadly, some of your friends do disappear
and it's not because they don't understand
what you're going through.
Intellectually, they do understand,
- Totally.
- but it's really hard
to relate to them.
I feel bad when it's like,
okay, let's go meet for brunch.
- Brunch isn't a thing when you have kids.
- I'm like brunch?
I can't do brunch--
- You say goodbye to brunch.
- Do you know what time I'm up
- What?
- in the morning?
- Brunch is the best.
- This was a big loss.
- This was a big loss,
- Yeah,
- like I feel like
- I do realize.
- my friendships were based on brunch.
- All friendships are based on brunch.
- My biggest fear was
being judged by people
who didn't know me as a mom.
- That is a problem.
You need to have friends
who you are comfortable
having come to your house, right?
Like you come to my house,
I don't feel like I need
a housekeeper coming over
before Ochi comes over.
- I think that's a good barometer.
If you can invite somebody to your house
without feeling the urge to clean--
- Yeah.
- They're gonna be a friend.
- Then they're a friend.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so what happens if your kid
makes a friend, but you
don't like that friend's mom?
- You tell them they moved away.
- That's the worst.
What if you don't have a mom BFF?
Don't worry if it
doesn't happen overnight.
I immediately thought
that because I'm a mom
I'm gonna bond with other moms
and we're just gonna be best friends.
- Don't sweat it man, you're gonna find
the perfect mom friend for you.
Your kid is gonna walk up to some stinky
little booger on the playground
and a beautiful friendship will be born.
- They may even be fighting.
- That's mine, that's mine, meh, meh, meh
and then both of you will look
in each other's eyes
- And just know.
Just know and you'll be like,
our kids are equal assholes,
let's hang out.
- Just like with non-parent
friendships and growing up.
They don't happen overnight.
- No.
- They develop over time.
- No matter what happens you
find your ride-or-die friends
after you have your kids.
- Absolutely, you find
your ride-or-die friend.
- For me, my family is like
- Yeah.
- My ride-or-die forever.
It's my husband and my kids.
My mom friends are people
who I would be friends with
if I wasn't a mom.
- Thank God for Ochi.
- Aww.
- I ship it.
(laughter)
- You guys stop shipping us,
we're married, it's so awkward.
(laughter)
- Hi.
- Whoo.
(laughter)
(upbeat banjo music)